bah ça enregistre là sa enregistre dans
une lettre à romain-rolland sigmund
freud écrit qu'il va visiter athènes il
raconte ça l'après midi dès notre
arrivée
quand je me trouvais sur la coupe hockey
l'après-midi de notre arrivée quand je
me trouvais sur l'acropole et que
j'embrassais le paysage du regard il me
vint subitement cette étrange idée
ainsi tout cela existe réellement comme
nous l'avons appris à l'école
il dit qu'à ce moment là il ya en ou
deux personnes qui se font face la
première qui en gros c'est comme s'il
fallait croire quelque chose qui jusque
là n'était pas si sûr en gros elle dit
en fait ça existe l'acropole
ok d'accord et la seconde qui pensait
pas qu'on doutait de l'existence de ces
choses là qui elle se dit avoir pu
douter de l'existence de l'acropole ok
je loue il raconte aussi on pourrait se
hasarder à dire qu'étant lycéens
on prétendait certes avoir été convaincu
par la réalité historique de la ville
d'athènes et de son histoire mais que
cette idée subite sur l'acropole révèle
justement qu'à cette époque
l'inconscient n'y avait pas cru
ce ne serait qu'une maintenant qu'on
aurait acquis une conviction plongeant
dans l'inconscient ce que décrit freud
vous l'avez peut-être vous même déjà
ressenti face à des monuments qui sont
vieux genre frais vieux genre d'un vieux
palpable quoi que tu peux toucher tout
un vieux tellement vieux que tu as du
mal vraiment à concevoir tout le temps
qui te sépare de cet objet là que tu
touches ou que tu observes c'est face à
ce type de monuments là qu'on peut
ressentir ce que freud a ressenti et
qu'il appelle le trouble de mémoire la
charpente de notre-dame c'était l'un de
ces monuments là qui font ressentir ce
qu'a ressenti fraude c'est à dire que
c'est tellement vieux que tu as du mal à
le concevoir et que tu as presque du mal
à y croire c'était des poutres qui
datent et parfois de 800 ans qui était
même dans un bois qui étaient pris d'un
chêne qui avait déjà 300 ans donc et
avec du bois qui étaient millénaire
donne enfin c'était incroyable c'est
difficile de décrire à quel point
c'était vieux et lundi soir j'étais
sûrement comme vous demandez écran
j'étais là à regarder cet incendie qui
ne finissait pas genre le moment où là
la flèche est tombé c'était vraiment un
coup de grâce vous saviez vous que ça
s'appelait la flèche et ça faisait mal
au coeur
c'était c'était physique avait le coeur
serré et je me suis demandé mais
pourquoi ce truc là nous tous
autant quoi parce qu'il ya des gens que
c'est beaucoup moins j'ai l'impression
mais avec sa touche beaucoup
moi j'en fais partie ça va vraiment fait
ça m'a vraiment rendu très triste et
donc j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi ça
nous touche autant je pense déjà qu'il
ya une partie qui n'est même pas lié au
fait qu'on soit français ou au fait que
ce soit notre nation j'ai passé au
souvenez quand vous voyez des shows
détruire des antiquités mésopotamienne à
palmyre ou dans le musée de mossoul
c'était horrible à voir c'était c'était
horrible ça rendait fou de rage est à la
fois c'était extrêmement triste donc ses
monuments et ses objets même s'ils sont
pas directement liées à la nation ça
nous fait mal de les perdre parce que
c'est une trace de l'humanité c'est une
trace de notre espèce alors évidemment
quand c'est au coeur de la capitale
ça fait encore plus mal michael billig
un universitaire britannique qui a
travaillé sur la psychologie sociale
explique dans son livre banane
nationalisa tu selon lui il y ait un rot
nationalism et un banal nationalisme je
le redis machine à raison le
nationalisme grotte vous pouvez pas
louper ces genres le défilé du 14
juillet c'est quand je chante la
marseillaise c'est quand on gagne la
coupe du monde
bref c'est tout ça tout ça et billy
explique que ce nationalisme le hôte il
a besoin d'un nationalisme banal de tous
les jours pour avoir du sens alors le
nationalisme banal donc ça va être les
passeports
ça va être voir des drapeaux ça va être
les euros avec les faces française ça va
être ce genre de choses la marianne sur
les timbres en gros c'est les petites
choses qui nous rappelle qu'on est en
france et pour billy
en fait les monuments les statuts elles
sont dans un endroit un petit peu floue
entre le hot et le banal quand on les
construit au moment de les construire
c'est du rot et petit à petit elles font
partie du paysage
elle se fonde un petit peu dans notre
environnement et ça devient du banal
alors parfois il ya des soucis comme aux
états unis récemment où il ya eu pas mal
de débats autour des statuts des soldats
confédérés
parce que parfois les statuts ou les
monuments représentent les idéologies
qui ne sont plus acceptables
en fait les idéologies bouge beaucoup
plus vite que les monuments protéger les
monuments ses protégés sa mémoire en
tant qu'individu mais aussi en tant que
société cédée et des fils qui nous offre
de la sécurité quelque chose
d'impalpable auquel on peut se rattacher
et qui va nous offrir de la confiance
la fierté alors quand on envoie un
boulet et massa nous attend au coeur un
endroit qu'on pensait intouchable et je
pense que c'est pour ça que l'incendié
notre dame
nous blesse autant alors évidemment on a
réussi à sauver plein de choses de l'
incendie il ya aussi des choses qui
n'étaient pas si vieille que ça donc
voilà ça c'est pour le côté un peu cool
j'ai fait une vidéo avec google art and
culture
il y a quelques années maintenant sur
justement comment les nouvelles
technologies permettait de conserver
l'arrêt à ce genre de choses je mets la
vidéo ici c'est en anglais sous-titré
est normalement s'ouvre la semaine
prochaine
love peace now et merci pour vos retours
sur la dernière vidéo